so today we're gonna talk about the
economics of being a woman by now
everyone knows that women only make 79
cents to the dollar and that's actually
why I shop at forever 21 so that I can
be reminded that I am forever 21 cents
less valuable than a man obviously we
need to narrow the wage gap and the
thigh gap and also the baby gap nothing
there fits meat equal pay for equal work
is a no brainer so let's talk about all
the women have to go through
just to make less than men let's start
at the beginning getting ready for work
it takes the average woman 3 times
longer to get ready than the average man
and even longer if you're ugly
that's extra time a man can spend
reading exercising or masturbating
whereas I have to multitask and let me
tell you it's hard to get through
Angela's Ashes while you're jackal
acting on an elliptical I know some of
you guys are probably just say like well
why don't you just stop putting on
your face we like you better without
makeup and to that I'll say a resounding
you someone in your family like no
I just woke up feeling pretty and
confident sorry won't happen again
here's the sixth thing studies show that
women who wear makeup actually earn more
money which those women are gonna need
because makeup is expensive as for Kurt
do you have any idea how much this costs
well what you mean the nose job
it took over an hour to do this tonight
and yes I do feel better about myself
with my mask on but it's only because
without it I don't deserve love
look it feels like it sometimes I know
damn well that being a woman is both
awesome and a complete pain in the ass
at times but I wanted to hear it from
someone who understands both sides of
the gender equations so I sat down with
a friend comedian Riley Silverman who
came out as a woman six years ago Riley
uh I haven't seen you for a while about
a long time you really do have an
interesting perspective because you
lived as a man and now you're living as
a woman do you enjoy the the extra
effort of being a woman I think at first
it was really enjoyable because like
it's like it's like ritual and you're
like oh my god I'm doing this this is
like this is my everyday life and then
after like a mom feel like this is my
everyday life has there been a spike in
costs since transitioning everything is
a little bit more money like everything
costs more like haircuts cost more
clothing is always more money for like
lower quality and then just even having
to buy makeup but this is that this adds
up really fast you're a pretty big
fashionista that's gonna be a huge
difference in your wardrobe yeah talk to
me about the changing cost there every
day so I have a different skirt and so
that's like in my morning there's a lot
of days where I'm that exact
stereotypical look I don't have anywhere
he's not a closet full of clothes yes
not only would it be that I would like
when I was living as a man but I just
wear a pair of like jeans every day it'd
be the same jeans like you'd wear the
same jeans for like a month
like how women wear bras yeah exactly do
you sleep in a bra
no and I like to eat I need it it's like
comforting because my mom never hugged
me it really is expensive being a woman
products directed at women like lotions
razors and shampoo consistently costs
more than similar products directed at
men because I guess it's pricey giving
all of our deodorants tiny ways if it
isn't shaped like a lady then hell I
know it's for me
they call this price discrepancy the
pink tax because I guess vaginas are
pink I don't know mine isn't whatever
but that's something that I don't think
a lot of men ever think about which
brings me to periods and sorry I know
I'm going to talk about periods for a
second but I'm on mine so I'll
do what I want
wait a little while
no a little while back we did a segment
called pay your tab cab where I picked
up guys from a strip club and then gave
them a chance to win money by answering
questions about women at one point in
their ride I asked these men to
demonstrate their knowledge of periods
here's what happened
all right it is time for the red zone
challenge are you ready
excited what we gotta do I am like on my
period right now here's $50 I just need
you to go inside there and just get me
anything that you think will help okay I
got all the good stuff yeah
stuffed turtle okay why this cuz when
you're cramping you need colors you know
you're sad and pink because cuz girl
okay well we've got you right here we
got you covered I got you to the page
what are those are my diapers they only
had a 34 pack and I don't know how many
you use put me pants do you think I'm
Mormon what the hell is this I don't
know how he works I'll just like I'll
roll these up and stick them up like
they're tampons
good cool that's fair these are than
essentials ready okay chocolate will
army okay okay we're talking
I even got three chocolate bars two for
you and one for me nice that you think
about yourself in these times anything
else
oh I got you lean crazy I'm on my period
not suicide watch
our thoughts are with you this is a
condolence card because you're going
you're not wrong for somebody who never
had a period before I think I did okay
you really did you really did yeah I
hope you get one I hope I don't get it's
a lot of for a period the minutes
and dollars it takes to look normal as a
woman add up so the next time I hear an
actor from some movie complaining about
oh I had to sit in a makeup chair for
three hours to look like a monster
try and remember that we do that every
day so people don't think we look like
monsters we'll be right back
hey this is Nikki Glaser and this is the
part of the video where I tell you to
watch more of my videos but I'm not
gonna tell you what to do instead I'm
just gonna look at you judging Lee